ja und das liebe zuschauer hier ist
super lieb freundlich hatte ein tolles
berlin ich meinen oxana war eine
des gegenstandes die ermittlung wir
der angenehme teil als die überraschung
nachricht von der ermordung oksanas in
oksana romberg eine promi kosmetikerin
und konnte es aber erst gar nicht
müssen überlegen das vielleicht vor
erfolgreiche heilpraktikerin war immer
geschäft am laufen und auf einmal zieht
kann sich wie verarbeitet man sowas
glauben weil ich kannte so was nicht
ihrer eigenen wohnung ist dass ihr
beziehung bestanden haben die eine
spricht man zu hause mit der familie
wird ermordet ist es her dass ging
aus berlin sie hat die schönen der
mörder mit diesen überwachungsvideo
also wir wissen alle das ist leider
zwangssituation damm entstehen lassen
darüber ich würde fast sagen man spricht
wurde gibt auf der welt aber es ist dann
vielleicht musste sie jemanden in die
erstmal gar nicht in meinen kopf rein
fahndet die polizei nach einem
schönen der hauptstadt noch schöner
besser nicht mit der familie darüber so
also ich behalte sie als lebenslustig in
wohnung lassen
einfach was ganz anderes andere sender
verdächtigen
gemacht zumindest in deren augen lippen
eindeutig es klingt wenn man muss gute
herzog wir hoffen alle dass wir diesen
diese überwachungskamera filmte den
zu fünf minuten weiter entfernt passiert
erinnerung sie war immer gut drauf und
neutralisation und kombinations
fall aufklären können dass sie diesen
und dann noch mit dem mann mit dem mann
voller stirn glatter doch dann die
hatte immer spaß mit ihr wenn man sie
zusammen gearbeitet hat die ermittler
techniken haben also bei mir war das
fall aufklären können ich danke ihnen
entscheidenden moment der moment wo der
getroffen hat also ich hab sie nicht
für diesen besuch heute hier
schock nachricht auch für ihre bekannten
sport jemand anders kann andere dinge
der berliner mordkommission haben
schlecht drauf erlebt sie war immer wird
mutmaßliche mörder von exane romberg
finden was man nicht machen sollte
patienten oxana wird tot in ihrer
folgende fragen wer kennt die person auf
helfen auch sie den angehörigen und
rauchen trinken oder seine aggressionen
sich laut positiven sinne also wirklich
hier in diesem innenhof unterwegs war
freunden von oxana homberg helfen sie
wohnung am kurfürstendamm gefunden die
dem überwachungsvideo und kann angaben
in anderer art und weise umwandeln ich
immer sehr positiver mensch noch immer
das video womit eben die polizei jetzt
zu ihrer identität machen er kann
der berliner polizei mit ihren hinweisen
bin kein sportler gewesen lange zeit
ermittler die tappen lange zeit im
scheint es keine heiße spur im mordfall
nach diesem mann fahndet und sucht warum
darüber hinaus angaben zur tat oder zum
aber daneben regeln ja man muss irgendwo
dunkeln wer hat das getan und vor allem
die ermittler der achten mordkommission
oxana homberg zu geben die 50-jährige
tatmotiv machen und wer hat frau romberg
warum musste sie sterben ja und dann
die energien fließen lassen ansonsten
ist dieses video auch so brisant weil
haben folgende fragen wer die
zerfrisst senders schon die segel das
behandelte in ihrem schönheitssalon am
verdächtige personen am 31 märz 2021 im
noch am mittwoch den 31 märz nach 18 uhr
taucht ganz plötzlich ein video auf das
wir hier in einem innenhof sind und dort
ist teilweise sehr schwierig und ganz
walter benjamin platz in berlin
auf lasst sie uns aktuell über diesen
charlottenburg seit jahren ihre kunden
einen mann zeigt der täter stefan xander
hinten da war eben der laden das
gesehen oder gesprochen
fall oxana sprechen wir haben eben
bereich des kurfürstendamms gesehen das
mit faltenunterspritzung botox
auch den promi freundin ist es ein
bilder einer überwachungskamera gesehen
geschäft von oxana romberg und der
behandlungen und augenbrauen korrekturen
und maximilian kiewel mit exklusiven
opfer hatte zahlreiche verletzungen am
großes anliegen dass der täter gefasst
die den mutmasslichen täter zeigen was
mutmaßliche mörder der war also hier
viele berliner promis gingen bei ihr ein
oberkörper vermutlich stichverletzungen
recherchen
wird ich habe es dann kann man zur ruhe
unterwegs und hat dann nachdem er hier
sagen die bilder aus also da sieht man
und aus dann am ersten april die schock
warum musste oksana romberg kurz vor
kommen wenn man wirklich weiß okay es
so wie es aussieht hat sich aber auch
ist aufgeklärt dass man auch weiß warum
eine runde gedreht hat dort den ausgang
ihr killer verletzt als er oxana
eine person vermutlich ein mann kleidet
ostern dieses jahres sterben prominente
überhaupt das ist absolut wichtig aber
genommen und ist womöglich oxana
homberg/ohm brachte in diesem
freunde und bekannte sind noch immer
das mit einer kapuze in dem gesicht
ich glaube ganz fest daran dass man auch
zusammenhang fragt die polizei natürlich
hinterhergelaufen
nicht zu erkennen und der läuft sehr
geschafft erstmal war bei mir alles so
den mörder finden wird also ich glaube
ob es auch eventuelle taxifahrer gibt
entspannend und ja man hat fast den
zuletzt wurde ob seiner romberg am 31
leer weil ich eigentlich noch nie
das ist ein super wichtig ist dass der
eindruck telefoniert er spricht mit sich
die in höhe kurfürstendamm 61 ein gast
mörder gefasst wird einfach dass dieser
jemanden durch den mord verloren habe so
beschäftigt sich mit sich selber also
märz gegen 18 uhr gesehen als sie sich
fall aufgeklärt wird und ist natürlich
einstiegen ließen der eventuell blut an
sieht nicht aus wie eine flucht und es
in meinem leben den ich gut kannte und
auch total komisches gefühl wenn man
auf den weg nach hause am kurfürstendamm
sieht auch nicht aus wie eine person die
weiß dass diese person der immer noch
den händen oder auch an der kleidung
61 machte für die strecke braucht sie
sehr unter druck vielleicht unter
frei draußen rum läuft man ja nicht weiß
weil das ist ja das schrecklichste was
hatte hinweise nimmt die mordkommission
anspannung steht ganz im gegenteil sehr
passieren kann also am morgen und dann
circa zwei minuten so die polizei waren
was dieser mensch sonst nach macht ja
unter folgender rufnummer entgegen 030
sehr ruhig und entspannend wirken diese
und sich jetzt vielleicht irgendwie auch
sie allerdings in ihrer wohnung ankamen
hast du noch dazu jemandem bezug dass
in sicherheit fühlen weil er ja bisher
bilder und es wird gute gründe geben
und ob sie zuvor noch an einem anderen
für berlin
4664 911
nicht gefasst wurde also das ist schon
das kannte ich vorher gar nicht und das
ort war ist nicht bekannt
warum die mordkommission hier gesagt hat
sehr komisch für hinweise die zur
war alles so surreal puh das war in
das sind bilder die für uns für die
888 vielen dank
fahndung für die ermittlung wichtig sind
diese schritte hier diesen gang den muss
ergreifung des täters führen hat die
oksana soll mit messerstichen getötet
staatsanwaltschaft berlin eine belohnung
auch der mörder von oxana romberg
von 5000 euro ausgesetzt
worden seien und der täter könnte sich
gegangen sein denn am ende dieses ganges
dabei auch selbst verletzt haben was
ja und wir wollen tiefer eintauchen in
da ist die wohnungstür zur wohnung von
kann da passiert seien das ist ein ganz
diesem fall haben unsere achtung
oxana romberg und was diesen fall so
spannender teil wenn sie an einem tatort
fahndungs experten professor christian
zusätzlich dramatisch macht die polizei
kommen sie haben einen menschen die ums
matzdorf ins studio eingeladen ja schon
hat hier keine einbruchspuren gefunden
leben gebracht worden ist sie können in
der leiche lesen wie in einem buch also
das heißt oxana die kannte den mann hat
genommen hermannsdorf schön dass die
sie erkennen anhand der verletzung was
zeit gefunden haben sie waren 30 jahre
passiert ist wieder ablauf der
ihn hereingebeten und hinter dieser tür
geschehensablauf war und man kann
lang bei der kripo auch hier in berlin
da hat sich dann die bluttat dieses
natürlich eine leiche auch erkennen ob
und zehn jahre lang auch im
die person sich gewehrt hat ob es
verbrechen abgespielt da war auf einmal
kriminaldauerdienst das heißt sie waren
abwehrverletzungen gibt ja vielleicht
total für polizei und hat nur die natur
oft der erste am tatort wie ist das dann
auch verletzungen von aktiven griffen
öffnet man so eine tür und dahinter
möglicherweise einen messer anderen
irgendwas ist da passiert was kennt man
liegt dann ein mordopfer ich hatte fast
gegenstand und da spricht vieles dafür
nicht dass da so viel los ist und dann
flip sich jetzt geantwortet so ganz
nach dem was wir jetzt hier wissen dass
war das ja auch schon minuten später auf
spontan man kann nicht mehr überrascht
es eine auseinandersetzung gab das ist
social media und das hatte ich ja
werden wenn man so lange in der
nicht eine überraschung war sondern
tatortarbeit ist aber das ist natürlich
tatsächlich dann eine auseinandersetzung
wirklich absolut schnell herumgesprochen
nicht richtig man lebt immer wieder
wo das opfer sich noch eine zeit lang
und ja da habe ich dann davon erfahren
dinge wir sind selber persönlich die
gewährt hat möglicherweise dann auch
sache mit den kindern wenn kinder
spuren blut oder andere dna spuren auf
geschädigt waren dort immer sehr nahe
gegangen wie erlebt immer wieder dinge
den realität übertragen hat und auf
hinter den türen die ein überraschender
seiner hand die tür auch anscheinend
freiwillig geöffnet ja wir wissen nicht
fund allerdings nicht vergessen dass
oftmals die kolleginnen und kollegen der
ob es tatsächlich freiwillig war da
schutzpolizei die ersten sind die dann
müssen wir überlegen also offensichtlich
eine tür öffnen und segen da ist eine
war sie in dem glauben dass er die
leiche dass jemand vielleicht umgebracht
worden und dann kommt die kripo schon
menschen die sie dort einlässt einlassen
kann ohne gefährdet zu sein ob das jetzt
mit einer gewissen wie soll ich sagen
vorwarnung an den das ist oftmals dann
freiwillig war oder ob es eine
vorgeschichte das ist ja auch ein teil
[Musik]